mes amis nous voilà de nouveau
rassemblés fidèle au poste
toujours les mêmes et pourtant déjà
différent on ne change pas par la seule
grâce d'un an
mais un nom contribue à nous changer
en choisissant ce nom de républicains
vous avez fait un choix c'est un choix
d'espérance mais c'est aussi un choix
d'exigence l'exigence c'était d'en finir
avec le temps des clans avec le délétère
confort de l'autre soit avec l'ignorance
de la force militante que vous incarnez
les uns et les autres et je veux te
remercier mon cher nicolas du travail
collectif que tu entrepris depuis ton
élection
oui cette nouvelle ère qui s'ouvre à
nous porte en elle l'exigence du service
commun avant les ambitions personnelles
elle nous impose un nouveau rapport avec
le peuple de france
un changement de logiciel dans notre
façon de faire de la politique
l'idée de république c'est d'abord
l'injonction de rassemblement et dans
cette salle et il y a des gaullistes et
j'en fais partie
il y a des libéraux et il y à des
centristes mais il y a surtout des
français amoureux de la france et de la
république
la république c'est notre bien le plus
précieux et nous avons décidé d'en faire
notre trait d'union
oui nous sommes les républicains parce
que nous ambitionnons de rassembler tous
les français sans la moindre
discrimination
nous nous ne trion pas les français nous
ne cherchons pas à faire triompher un
camp contre un autre
nous voulons simplement faire gagner la
france
et pour y parvenir elle a besoin
de tous ces enfants nous voulons
rassembler tous ceux qui ne baissent pas
les bras
tous ceux qui conservent en eux malgré
la dureté des temps
une lueur d'espoir dans le futur de la
nation
nous voulons passer avec la france un
nouveau pacte
chacun y aura sa place l'ouvrier qui se
désespère en voyant nos industries
péricliter
l'employé qui s'exaspèrent de voir son
pouvoir d'achat baisser quand d'autres
s'enrichissent sans même se donner la
peine de travailler
l'étudiant auquel on ne promet qu'un
ticket à pôle emploi l'artisan accablé
de domme imbéciles le chef d'entreprise
suffocant sous les taxes
nous voulons rassembler les professeurs
et les parents qui assistent médusés à
l'attentât perpétré contre l'école de la
république
ce que le pouvoir socialiste veut
détruire
c'est en fait un rien de moi que ce qui
fait lien au sein de la nation ses
références ses valeurs son histoire son
identité et son authenticité
les mêmes qui proclame je suis charlie
sont en train de chasser voltaire ils
sont dangereux et il faut les empêcher
ono même du 11 janvier de commettre
leurs méfaits
nous voulons rassembler les
intellectuels les créateurs ceux qui
font vivre l'exemplarité de la culture
française
nous voulons réunir tous ceux qui
veulent que l'état remplisse sa première
fonction qui consiste à assurer la
sécurité de tous en respectant les
libertés de chacun nous entendons faire
vivre et prospérer l'esprit de
résistance face à la menace djihadiste à
l'extérieur comme à l'intérieur
sans excès mais sans faiblesse car il y
à là pour la france un danger mortel
la liste de ceux qui doutaient enragé
longue
c'est le terreau sur lequel prospère les
arnaqueurs de l'extrême qui sur le fond
se retrouve aujourd'hui dans un front
commun
alors certes nous mêmes nous n'avons pas
tout réussi mais nous avons tant tout
tenté et mieux réussi que d'autres
valait-il mieux être en 2010 2e en
europe derrière l'allemagne
qu'aujourd'hui les derniers de l'europe
malgré la reprise de la croissance dans
la plupart des pays européens
le moins que l'on puisse dire est que
monsieur hollande et ses ministres
s'emploie chaque jour aggravé les choses
ils le font avec une application
idéologique absolue avec une obstination
insensé si nous combattons les
socialistes et les extrémistes
ce n'est pas par sectarisme c'est parce
que nous avons la conviction qu'ils font
du mal à la france que nous aimons nous
avons le devoir de créer les conditions
de l'alternance autour d'un projet de
sauvegarde nationale et cette alternance
c'est déjà maintenant avec nos derniers
succès aux élections départementales
nous nous lançons dans la bataille des
régionales avec mes amis de la région
provence alpes côte d'azur jean claude
gaudin hubert falco eric ciotti garneau
muselier julien aubert et tant d'autres
nous allons tout mettre en oeuvre et
toute notre énergie j'en prends
l'engagement devant vous pour mettre un
terme au pouvoir absolu du parti
socialiste depuis 17 ans et empêcher
qu'elle ne tombe sous la coupe de la
dynastie le pen oui vous êtes les
artisans de la victoire
vous êtes les combattants de la nation
vous êtes les soldats de la république
ce soir en rentrant chez vous soyez
fiers de ce que nous avons commencé à
construire aujourd'hui avec nicolas
sarkozy
soyez fiers de vous soyez fiers de votre
parti soyez fiers d'être les
républicains